한시간에 18. 저 여기 주차했다가
깜짝 놀랐습니다. 거의 뉴욕 주차장
가격인 거 같아요.
>> 어, 이거 왜 주차장 쓰고 있지?
주차장 수익이 좋은가? 제일 큰 건
바로 입니다. 네. 네. 안녕하세요.
어, 여러분들 지나다가 정말 좋은
위치에 정말 좋은 땅인데 주차장으로
사용하고 있는 그런 부지들을 많이
보셨을 것 같아요. 왜 과연이 좋은
땅의 주차장 부지로 사용하고 있는지
오늘 좀 설명을 드릴 건데 [음악]
좀 집중해 주시면 좋을 것 같습니다.
어, 일단은이 좋은 땅에 왜
주차장으로 사용하고 있는지의 가장 큰
이유는 바로 세금 때문이에요. 땅들은
두 가지 분류로 좀 분류가 됩니다.
그래서 첫 번째는 사업용 토지.
그리고 두 번째는 비사업용 토지.
[음악] 그래서 비사업용 토지 같은
경우에는 말 그대로 사업하지 않고
그냥 내쁜 땅이에요. 그래서이 땅
같은 경우에는 종합 합상 과세도 되고
공제율도
굉장히 낮기 때문에 세금 부담이
굉장히 커질 수가 있습니다. 그리고
무엇보다 공시 지가가 일정 금액 이상
되면은 종부세 대상이 [음악] 돼요.
그래서 저는 이런 경우도 봤어요.
그래서 고객분이 건물을 짓기 전에
일단 그냥 건물을 부셔 놨어요. 네.
부셔 놨다가 설계를 하는데 설계
기간이 생각보다 오래 걸려 [음악]
가지고 그 6월 1일 기준으로 그냥
빈땅으로 가지고 있었던 겁니다.
그리고 이제 나중에 종합 부동산세가
나온 거예요. 진짜 몇 천만 원을
냈습니다. 그래서 많은 분들이 일단은
그냥 건물부터 부시고 그냥 놀리고
있는 경우가 생각보다 많거든요.
그래서 이렇게 비사업용 토지로
인정됐을 때 종부세 대상이 될
[음악] 수 있다라는 거 좀 알고
계시면 좋을 거 같고 그리고 나중에
매각할 때 양도세도 증가돼요. 네.
양도세도 10% 증가됩니다. [음악]
그래서 비사업용 토지에 대한 이런
세금 부담이 굉장히 크기 때문에 이런
빈땅을 가지고 계신 분들은 [음악]
사업용 토지로 인정을 받아야 돼요.
그래서 그 대안 중에 하나가 바로
주차장입니다. 그래서 주차장을
사용함으로 인해서 이거는 비사업
토지가 아니다. 사업용 토지로
인정받아야 된다라고 해 가지고 운영을
하는데 그 운영 요건들이 있습니다.
그래서 직접 운영을 해야 되고
[음악] 사업자 등록증을 내야 되고
그리고 일정 기준 이상의 매출도
나와야 되고 그래서 그 조건에 해당이
돼야지만이 사업용 토지로 인정을 받을
수 있습니다. 그래서 이렇게 받았을
때는 공제율도 높아져서 종부세 대상도
제외될 수도 있고 양도세 중가도 따로
없습니다. 그래서 이런 빈땅을 가지고
계신 분들은이 사업용 토지가 되게
중요하기 때문에이 요건들을 좀 보시면
좋을 것 같아요. 근데 하나 또
아셔야 될게 그 [음악] 팔기 전에
양도세 중가 안 받으려고 갑자기
주차장으로 쓰시는 분들이 있거든요.
근데 그것도 일정 기간 이상이 지나지
않으면 인정받을 수 없습니다. 무조건
세법은 실질 과세 원칙이에요. 그래서
[음악] 실제로 내가 주차장을
운영했는지 실제로 주차장을 운영해서
매출이 발생됐는지에 [음악]
따라서 세금을 부과하기 때문에
주차장으로 진짜 몇 년 동안 실제로
사용을 해야 되고 그리고 개인이냐
법인이냐에 따라서 또 세율도 달라지기
때문에 이건 미리 사전에 전문가
상담을 받아보시는 걸 좀 권하고
싶습니다. 네. 그리고 또 이런
대안도 있어요. 주차장으로 사용할 수
있지만 [음악] 세 차장으로 쓰시는
분들도 있어요. 제가 세 차장 운영할
때 사실 비용이 그렇게 많이 들진
않거든요. 건물 짓는 거보다 사실
부담이 좀 덜하긴 하잖아요. 그래서
세차장으로 쓰시는 분들도 많이
생겨나고 있습니다. 그래서 사실 강남
한복판에 주차비가 되게 비싸잖아요.
수익성이 그래도 나오긴 하지만. 어,
근데 가장 큰 문제는 바로이 [음악]
보유세랑 양도세 때문에 그렇게 사업용
토지로 인정받기 위해서 사용하고
있다라고 보시면 될 거 같아요. 저런
분도 계세요 그냥 이제 주택의 세금이
너무 부담돼서 [음악] 주택 건물이
너무 관리하기도 힘들고 주택 같은
경우에는 다른 재산이 있는 경우에는
되게 부담도 크고 그래 가지고 그냥
주택 건물 일단 부셔 놓는 경우도
있거든요. 우리 회사 옆에도 사실
주택 건물이었는데 그냥 부셨거든요.
세금 부담이 되게 커 가지고. 네.
근데 이렇게 부셨을 때 그런 종부세랑
나중에 이제 양도세 중가가 이슈가 될
수가 있어요. 그래서 [음악] 진짜
아무 생각 없이 푸시는 분들 생각보다
많습니다. 그냥 놀리고 있는 경우가
되게 많거든요. 근데 [음악] 이런
경우는 되게 조심해야 돼요. 내가
나중에 비사업용 토지가 될지 아니면
사업용 [음악] 토지가 될지를 미리
좀 판단을 해 가지고 선택하면 좋을
거 같습니다. 네. 그래서 제가 오늘
설명드렸던게 일반적인 세율 구조라고
보시면 될 거 같아요. 그래서 자세한
거는 내가 개인이냐 법인이냐 [음악]
아니면 어떤 부동산을 가지고 있느냐에
따라서 다를 수 있기 때문에 이건
사전에 미리 전문가와 충분한 상담을
받으시면 좋을 것 같습니다. 어,
그리고 제가 다음 달에 이제 스터디를
시작을 [음악] 합니다. 그래서 지금
37기 모집 중에 있고 10년 동안
한 강의고 정말 줄이고 수정하고
줄이고 수정하고 해 가지고 빌딩
투자하 있어서 도움이 될 만한
내용들을 준비를 했으니까 빌딩 투자에
관심 있다라고 [음악] 하시면이
스터디 어 들으시면 절대 후회 안
하실 거라고 저는 확신을 합니다.
그래서 제가 링크에 달아 놨으니까
강의에 관심이 있으신 분들 링크 타고
들어와서 어 빌딩 투자하는데 도움이
되셨으면 좋겠습니다. 그래서 오늘은
여러분들이 많이 궁금해하실 만한
빈땅에 왜 주차장으로 쓸까라는 주제로
좀 촬영을 했고요. 여러분들
추가적으로 또 궁금한 거 있으시면
언제든지 댓글 [음악] 남겨 주시면
저희가 참고해서 새로운 콘텐츠로 되게
알찬 정보로 다시 좀 찾아오도록
하겠습니다. 오늘 영상 여기까지
하겠습니다. [음악] 감사합니다.